So guys like myself you're probably
wondering when is when is it because the
thing is it's an opportunity not to be
missed and I'll give the example of the
dunya so somebody can understand but
obviously beyond that subhan allah if
someone said to me you're going to get
a100 million pounds I'll be I don't
really care£100 million but let's
suppose people monitoring and they said
to me you got 10 days within this 10
days if you for example um get this
raffle ticket every day or whatever it
is for that matter yeah you have a
chance of winning it now someone in
their right mind would not come and say
hm I I want to do it every day. I would
go through the days that are most
likely. The one that's clever, who wants
to win the£100 million would say, I'm
going to put I'm going to make sure
every single night, those 10 nights, I'm
going to put a whatever it is for that
matter. Yeah. Absolutely. So obviously
Allahh is offering something far far
greater. Better than 83 years. So she
when is how does one not miss it? We
want a small short hack. Subhan Allah.
Guess what? Yes.
You know quarreling yes it never brings
any good fighting and so let me tell you
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was coming to tell the sahaba about
because he knew about it. Okay. He was
coming to and two people started
quarreling. Wow. So he went to see in
for between them and he was made to
forget it. Subhan Allah. And he told
them he said I came I came to tell you
about but then these two were quarreling
so I was made to forget it. It's like a
m battle when they told him don't come
down. Don't come down. He has a conclus
everybody. Absolutely. So so what
happens is this is this hadith teaches
us not to quarrel. Leave the quarrels
because there is nothing good that come
out of quarreling. How many people call
over the 10 nights? Subhan Allah. Yeah.
Exactly. Subhan Allah. Subhan. Okay. So
what does one do to make sure they catch
it? Well the there are we have got a
difference of hadith but we need to
combine between the for example we have
hadith inkari
from when he
says Ramadan that seek it in the last 10
days of Ramadan last 10 days days or
night or you mean the whole day? Yeah
the whole day
so in here when we say day it means day
and night. Okay so
Ramadan, seek it in the last 10 days of
Ramadan. Then we have other that say uh
seek it in the last seven. Oh okay. So
last seven it means last seven it would
mean the odd nights. So and then there
is a a hadith seek it in the in the
seventh night in the fifth night and
then the ninth night. So that means the
night of the 25th, the night of the 27th
and the night of the 29th. Okay. There
are other aid that it was on the night
of the 21st. A hadith that it was on the
night of the 25th. A hadith that it was
on the night of the 27th. So if we kind
of like if everybody just choose a
hadith that he likes and say, "Okay,
it's 27th." Like now it's everybody just
the massagid after the 27th are empty
and there's no certainty. No certainty.
So what we do look the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam did in the
beginning of Ramadan for 10 days then he
did in the middle of Ramadan then he did
in the last 10 of Ramadan. He said that
he was seeking for that special night
and he was made to see it in the last
10.
So do like alhamdulillah you know you
can do in the last 10 of Ramadan and try
to do as much as you can in the last 10
then like as you said like the example
the analogy that you gave about the the
million pound you won't miss it 100%. So
okay that's so what that means is that
every day what I do personally is make
sure every single night of the last 10
nights I do a bit of Quran salah and I
have to and I try to do it every single
day cuz then you don't miss it you
should anyone that comes and says you
cannot something like this you can't say
oh it's the 27th brother if you don't
want to miss it you do it every night
now the issue we have is this the odd
night can change it does because if the
Ramadan is 29 days that means that the
21st first night that you f was the 21st
or the 27th that you f 27 was actually
the 26th. So that means what? Treat
every day like it's that odd night like
it's because you know what it will make
you do? Go that extra mile. Look the the
other thing which is very important. You
know another thing that we can take from
the that the scholars have said that it
changed every year. There you go. So, so
for example, we have got a hadith that
it was on the 27th, but we have got
other hadith that it was on the 21st.
So, that means
every so, so the solution is what the
solution that you do every night
standing stand in prayer.
The prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said, "Whosoever stands in prayer during
the night of out of and in anticipation
that his sins will be forgiven for
forgiven all his previous sins will be
forgiven. all these previous and just to
give some context brothers and sisters
if you guys are watching this inshallah
brother and sisters we want you
inshallah to donate to all causes
Palestine Yemen as well but if you do
have anything inshallah which you do
left brothers and sisters we have got
the salah pass project where we just
don't guided prayer mats and just
imagine brothers and sisters a revert or
a born Muslim who doesn't know how to
pray salah learn how to do wudoo by our
woodoo guide learn how to pray salah
learn surah fatya so that's ablution
prayer and Quran Imagine the you get
guys, we've got onetoone salah
instructors that we teach people how to
pray salah. We're printing 50,000 of
these mats in seven languages and
distributing to da tables, masids, uh
prisons, 150 prisons we're working,
alhamdulillah, ISOs, and we singly
distribute them across the world as
well. We've got salah hubs where
workshops are happening where we're
aiming of teaching 26,000 people a year.
We've got our app coming that's going to
have a free kibla finder, free salah
reminders, free you can order your
guided prayer mat, book a salah
instructor, book a Quran instructor, um
find your local salah and many more
guys. And if today is or whichever one
you want to give in a£100 donation could
be equivalent to what 300,000 a,000
donation could be equivalent to 3
million them how do you work out and how
because it's eight we the way I do is 83
times 365 times times that inshallah it
comes to 30,295 days so if someone gives
one pound it's as if you gave 30 pounds
actually if you give 10 pounds is
300,000 if you give a 100 pounds it's£3
million if you give a thousand pounds
it's 30 million And if someone donates
£10,000, it's as if you've given three
no 150 million million if I'm not
mistaken. Yes. No, that's for 5,000. For
10,000, we did it for 5,000. 300
million. 300 million. There you go. From
sisters, the link is there in teach
someone how to pray salah. It's a
beautiful
water orphanage. Teaching someone how to
pray salah who could live for 10, 20,
30, 40, 50, 60 or 70 years is a that in
outlive any water. Well, not that
there's anything wrong with the water.
Well, go to the link and donate now.